guys getting
stuck on this idea be they
they don't vet women properly then you
know what i mean
so like the suggestion from gary chapman
in in the book
is that um guys pay attention did you
read the book
oh yeah you did it yep i read i read
through i know
i read absolutely that's how i can
criticize it so well
i i read things like criticize too but
you know i um
i read all of the you know crappy
relationship books
you know before i scott came into you
know pick up an evo psych and eventually
like
rational mail and those other things i
read all that stuff when i was in
trying to figure out what were some
other crappy ones that you read i'm just
curious
oh men are from mars women are from
venus this
is horrifying um and i have to go
through
some of the other titles like i think
there's stuff by joel olsteen is
horrifying
yeah like i've seen a few on the amazon
list now in in the dating slash
relationship category because my book
does well in it i mean it's not even in
the top five
um i mean it's generally in the top 20
or so usually but
um i've noticed like these books in the
top five and the titles and the authors
i've never heard of but it's like it
just looks like woo
[ __ ] i've thought i've often thought
about doing a
breakdown on on like the number one
selling book in the relationship
category just from you know the
perspective of somebody like me that's
kind of made his wounds his work and did
all the [ __ ] and wrote his own book on
it
i think that might be fun at some point
to do maybe we'll do a book club paul
what do you say
yeah yeah book club where we just tear
apart these
well i don't know maybe we'll praise it
maybe we'll tear it apart depends on
what's
that's true i i do i do look at things
as objectively as possible and i try to
make you know i try to maintain like an
understanding of their audience too
i mean there's a lot of things like our
audience tends to be primarily men
but you know there's a way to present
information too that resonates better
with women
and so if you're trying to be a little
bit more universal they're not they're
not going to be so
cold hard truth bomb harsh about certain
things and i can accept that but
when it's just bad advice though that
leads to failure
that's when we're having a problem i can
accept the lukewarm way of
presenting maybe what would be good
advice i don't accept the bad advice
that's going to destroy
you know further destroy people's
relationships
and um in case in point so chapman
says you know that when you're you know
you're dating and courting and all that
stuff that you're supposed to be paying
attention
to how she treats others and her the way
she expresses herself to others to try
to determine what
her love language is and then you try to
match that and all the stuff
again you're paying attention to all the
wrong things
so instead of paying attention to the
signs that she has genuine desire for
you
and that signs that she's you know has
that you're her best
and that she sees you as an apex alpha
and maybe the signs that she's capable
of pair bonding
looking at those red flags looking at
those green flags and those things
guys are focused on trying to figure out
what her love language is well here's
the problem with that too
how she expresses let's say love to her
mom
or or you know her friends isn't gonna
be how she treats a guy she's
genuinely into right and so
yeah sorry just about to say i just
pulled up the book on amazon because i
wanted to see how it sells it sells
really well dude i know dude there's
almost 50
000 reviews on it and yeah judging by
the
ratio of reviews to sales online
this guy sold a [ __ ] ton of these
you know you know when i first realized
that that that this was [ __ ]
and in full transparency uh
i haven't read it so i don't i don't
know what's in the content of the book i
mean i've gone through the quiz
um many years ago the time we just did
it now just for jokes
it says over 12 million copies hold but
i mean the time that i knew that this
was [ __ ]
um i'm in a bunch of different facebook
groups and i don't usually participate
i'm just a fly on the wall because i
don't want to drop red pill truce on on
people that aren't ready for them but i
like to see what they're dealing with so
in like a uh couples group
or sorry like a men's group that's
that's dealing with
relationship struggles there's guys
that'll come on and they'll be like you
know my wife hasn't had sex with me in
forever
and you know she's always nagging me and
i'm very stressed out about it and
i don't know what to do and what do you
think guys and it's like a good chunk of
the feedback that they'll get is we'll
find out what her love language is
and then go and serve that right exactly
and it's like oh
man well and it's no it should be of no
surprise then
that only one out of 10 relationships or
according to the study that you showed
are successful and happy correct oh
past the nine past the eight year mark
you know and even sooner than that they
usually fall apart but that study was
done past
eight you know to the eight year mark
it's it's of no surprise
long-term relationships don't last
because
they're they're picking all the stuff
that sets them up for failure
so if we don't challenge this stuff you
know what i mean it's just going to
continue
it's it's still the number one selling
book in the marriage category
yep absolutely the number one selling
book and
and there's beta males that are going to
go out there and buy it after they've
been doing the dishes and taking the
kids to all the extracurriculars and
mopping the floors like darren hardy
says
doing all that [ __ ] and then they're
gonna go and buy the book and do more of
that stuff thinking that that's going to
get them
what they want in that marriage and it's
i mean it's a tragedy that that more
guys don't understand the difference
between
genuine desire and [ __ ] indifference
really which is what women have at that
point
yeah absolutely well and it's completely
different like
when she when she has genuine desire for
you and she sees you as her apex alpha
the way you do something and and how you
do something
she'll respond completely different to
that than if she sees you as that guy
she settled with
kind of a beta and the genuine desire
really isn't there and it's a negotiated
relationship
her you you could do the dishes okay
because you know what you're just gonna
do the dishes today because you got
she's busy with some stuff
you know you you you whatever you know
what i mean and you just do them that's
fine right
and she's going to be more she'll look
at something like that really
appreciative
whereas with a beta guy she looks at
that as his duty
you know what i mean well you're
supposed to do that it has nothing to do
with love language
it has to do with how she feels about
you you know and so guys need to get
better at seduction
and get better at vetting well first
vetting but also better at seduction
and better at maintaining frame and
genuine desire
in the relationship that's how you have
the success
not by setting it up further into a
negotiated situation
because that never works you can't can't
negotiate desire no
utterly pointless it leads to compliance
and ultimately resentment
you